after the coronavirus southern nevada's
first large-scale vaccination site is
now open
this is over at cashman center downtown
also a major testing center of course
vaccinations are by appointment only
though for people 70 and older
yet today vaccinations are just for
first responders with
appointments i'm looking forward to it
i think that we need to be courageous
and understand would help each other
i think everybody's doing pretty much
the best they can do under the
circumstances right now
the southern southern nevada health
district is asking everybody to be
patient with the vaccination process
it's been a bit of a challenge
now we're hearing a lot of questions
from you at home about the vaccine and
about how to get it
health officials say you have to fill
out a form first
has some basic questions and asks for
your contact information
and when it's time for you to get
vaccinated in your age group
you'll get notified there are also
specific forms for those of you who are
elderly
we have a link to all of this
information at 8newsnow.com